as far as I know we've never developed a
protocol for dealing with intelligent
life beyond Earth because we haven't
even come close to finding it yet
[Music]
I think it's really hard for people to
think about how far these distances are
I mean the closest star to us is Alpha
Centauri it would take tens of thousands
of years to get there and so to be an
advanced society like ours again we're
so far from being able to travel those
distances and yet we consider ourselves
to be pretty pretty advanced and so at
this point in time certainly at NASA we
don't really worry about encountering
intelligent life from elsewhere just
because it's so hard all those distances
there are private groups like SETI
who monitor radio signals to try to see
if we can hear anything coming from
those faraway stars but we haven't heard
anything to date you know chances are
there are billions of stars out there
billions of galaxies somewhere else
there has to be an advanced civilization
but again I guess I'm more dubious given
the fact that we consider ourselves so
advanced and we have so little ability
to